in this video we're going to see if we
can graph a rational function a raffle
rational function is just a function
that has an expression on the numerator
and the denominator has a polynomial in
the numerator let's say we have x
squared over another polynomial in the
denominator x squared minus 16 we could
obviously graph this by just trying out
a bunch of points and then connecting
the dots that's what a calculator would
do for us a graphing calculator but we
want to do is before we try out some
points to kind of fill in the gaps I
would understand the basic structure of
this graph first and to understand that
I want to see what happens as X gets
really big so X gets really big or X
gets really really small as X goes in
the negative direction or another way we
could think about it I want to
understand what happens as the magnitude
of X or the absolute value of x becomes
really big as it approaches really
really big miss or as it approaches
infinity so with the size of X
approaches infinity which essentially is
saying as X goes really far in the
positive direction or X goes really far
in the negative direction what is going
to happen to the value of this function
so let's get out a calculator we'll use
the graphing part of it just yet but
let's just try out some values what
happens when X is equal to 10 and yeah
it's going to be the same thing as when
X is equal to negative 10 because when
you put a negative 10 here you square it
you get 100 just like 10 same your
negative 10 you square it you get the
same thing as a positive 10 so whether
you go in the super high positive
direction or the super low negative
direction as you approach positive or
negative infinity you're going to
approach the same thing because you're
squaring the values but let's try out
some values if I get 10 squared divided
by divided by 10 divided by 10 squared
minus 16 I get 1 point 1 9 now what
happens if X gets a little bit bigger
this is X is equal to 10 what happens
when X is equal to 100 we have 100
squared divided by divided by 100
squared minus
sixteen I'm getting even closer to one
this was what what it was X was ten when
X is ten around here we're getting Y is
one point one nine when X is one hundred
one hundred squared over one hundred
squared minus 16 y is one point zero
zero one six this for fun let's try a
thousand so it's one thousand squared
divided by 1000 squared minus sixteen
and we're even closer to one so as X as
the size of X gets larger and larger and
larger our Y gets closer and closer to
one and that would also be true if this
was a negative ten because negative ten
squared over negative 10 squared minus
16 is going to be the exact same thing
because the negative when you square it
is going to be a positive it's going to
be the same thing as 10 squared same
thing over here
so whether X gets really big or X gets
really small we're going to be
approaching Y is equal to one you could
try it with a million if you want you're
going to get a number even closer to one
so it's the size of X approaches
infinity the absolute value of x or the
distance from the origin approaches
infinity Y is approaching Y is
approaching one or another way to think
about it is the graph of this function
is going to approach the line y is equal
to one so let me graph the line y is
equal to one so I'll do it in a dotted
line because this is the graph of our
function but this is a line that our
function is approaching so that is the
graph of y is equal to one now this idea
of a function or the graph of a function
approaching a line but never quite
touching so this going to get closer and
closer and closer to this line y equal
to one in that direction but never quite
getting too close close enough to it'll
it'll get it'll approach zero its
distance from this y equal one but never
quite get there this line that the graph
is approaching is called an asymptote as
simple and it'll be even more clear once
I actually graph the function we're
going to work up there and since it's a
horizontal line we call this a
horizontal
some tote horizontal asymptotes this is
what our graph approaches as we go to
the positive direction or really far in
the negative direction let's think about
some of the other interesting things
about this about this function right
here well one thing that might pop out
at you is this is a difference of
squares this is x squared minus 4
squared so we can rewrite this as x
squared over X plus 4 times X minus 4 so
what's going to happen here as X
approaches either positive 4 or X
approaches negative 4 well first of all
try those values out if X is equal to 4
what is going to happen this expression
right here this term right here is going
to be equal to 0 and we're going to be
dividing by 0 we cannot do that
similarly if X is equal to negative 4
we'd be dividing by 0 this expression
right here is going to be equal to 0 we
can't we can't do that so this this we
could say that this function function is
undefined undefined at X is equal to
plus or minus 4 it can't equal those
values because we be dividing by 0 in
either one of those circumstances now
what happens as we approach those values
what happens as X what happens as X
approaches what happens as X approaches
negative 4 let's just do that one for
fun what happens as X approaches
negative 4 and let's look at it from
let's say let's say we're approaching it
from the negative direction from the
negative direction so let's try it out
in our calculator let's try it out in
the calculator so let's say we want to
go from the negative direction so let's
start with negative 4 point 1 so if we
have if we have negative four point one
negative four point one squared divided
by divided by
negative four point one squared minus 16
what do we get we get twenty point seven
five so we get this number
whatever let's see if we get even closer
to negative four so let me just get that
entry there so let's get a little bit
closer to negative four so let me
instead of four negative four point one
let's do negative four point oh one so
let me insert let me insert a negative
so let me insert a negative four point
oh one and then over here this is
negative four point zero one four point
oh one and see what it is now we went to
200 so we're getting to larger and
larger values let's try four negative
four point zero one let's try that out
let's try that out
whoops that's not what I wanted to do I
wanted to do that so let's try no that's
not what I want to do let's see so we
want to go to instead of four point zero
one I want to do four 0.001 and over
there negative four point zero one four
point zero one and what do we get we get
two thousand so as we get closer and
closer to negative four from the
negative direction we're approaching
larger and larger super larger numbers
and you could try if it's for 0.0001
it's going to get to smaller and smaller
numbers or sorry larger and larger
numbers here you know if you do 4.00 one
it's probably going to be a 20,000 and
then if you add another zero here so as
we get closer and closer it's getting to
larger and larger numbers so we could
say as X approaches negative four we
could say Y is approaching infinity it's
getting to a larger and larger and
larger value but we can never quite get
to X is equal to four it's undefined
there that will make the denominator
here equal to zero so we want to do here
is we can never quite equal X equal
negative four so let me see X is equal
to one two three four we can never quite
get to X is equal to negative four let
me draw X is equal to negative four is a
dotted line right there that is X is
equal to negative four
X is equal to negative or we can never
quite get there but as we approached it
from the negative side as we had you
know four point one then four point oh
one we went to larger and larger values
and we also know that we want on the
left hand side as we go to larger and
larger X values that Y will get closer
and closer to one so you have a general
sense of what this part of the graph
will look like this part of the graph is
going to look something like that as X
gets to super negative numbers it gets
closer and closer to one as X gets
closer and closer to negative four from
the negative direction it's going to go
closer and closer to infinity you're
going to get closer and closer to a very
it's going to get larger and larger I
guess this is an easy way to say now
just like X equal negative four x equals
four will also be a point where the
graph is undefined so let me graph that
here one two three four right here right
right over here X is equal to four and
once again what happens is we approach x
equals four let's say from the positive
direction so as X approaches 4 from the
positive direction what's going to
happen so this is like trying out X is
equal to 4.01 or X is equal to four
point zero one or X is equal to four
point zero one so we're just getting
closer and closer and closer to X is
equal to four well these values are the
exact same values that we just tried on
our calculator except they're the
negative version of them right and we
already saw that just the way that this
function is set up the negative numbers
they get squared so the whether you take
the negative or the positive x values
it's going to be the same thing this
graph is symmetric when X is equal to
negative 5 is the same thing as X is
equal to 5 when X is equal to negative
10 is the same thing as x equals 10 so
the same thing is going to happen you
could try it out with your calculator if
you like if you try out these values
you're going to see as we get closer and
closer to 4 we're going to approach
larger and larger numbers these same
numbers over here so the graph over here
we're going to get we're going to as we
get closer and closer to 4 we're going
to approach larger and larger numbers
and then here as X gets larger and
larger larger we solve for here we had
these horizontal happens to asymptote
gets closer and closer to one so just
like we called just as we called this a
horizontal asymptote these values or you
can even view these vertical lines X is
equal to negative 4 and X is equal to 4
we call these vertical asymptotes
vertical asymptotes simp Toad's these
are lines asymptotes once again there
are lines that the graph approaches but
never quite touches so that's what's
going on here and then we can think
about what's happening what's happening
to the graph inside of here so you could
think of it in a couple of ways you
could say well what's happening what
happens as X approaches let's say what
happens as X approaches 4 from the
negative direction so let's try that out
from the negative direction so what
happens if you do 3.9 squared divided by
3 point 9 squared minus 16 you get
negative 19 point 2 5 now what happens
if we do 3 point 9 9 so let me put
another 9 here so we're going to get
closer and closer to 4 we're going to do
it from the from from the left hand side
as we approach 4 so insert another 9
here so even more negative so let's just
do one more we're going to be even more
negative let me make it 3 point 9 9 9
get even closer get even closer to 4 get
even closer to 4 you're getting even
more negative and this is also going to
be true if we did negative 3 point 9 or
negative 3 point 9 9 or negative 3 point
9 9 9 because that we when we squared
the negatives and the positives are the
same thing you square negative 1 you get
a positive 1 so as we approach as we
approach 4 from you know you go 3.9 3.9
9 we get closer and closer 4 we get
large we get more and more negative
numbers we approach negative infinity so
as we approach
let me just graph it here we're going to
get as we approach from this direction
we're going to smaller on
not touch our asymptotes I'm just going
to look at something like that as we
approach it from the left-hand side
reading smaller and smaller numbers and
that's also going to be true as we
approach negative 4 from the right hand
side right as we get negative three
point nine three point nine nine three
point nine nine nine we're going to drop
down it's going to look something like
that and then we now that we have a
general sense of what the graph is now
is a good time where we could maybe plot
a few points here so what happens and
easiest one is what happens when X is
equal to zero you have zero squared over
zero squared minus 16 so that's so the
point when X is equal to zero we're
going to have 0 over well negative 16
which is just 0 so the point 0 0 the
point 0 0 is on this curve and then we
could try some other points if you like
but the general shape here is going to
look something like this it's going to
look something like this you could you
could plot more points if you really
want to nail down exactly what the curve
is doing in between but here is the
general structure and you know we tried
out a lot of values with the calculator
and I did that because I really wanted
to show you why it's dropping down like
this and if you think about it it makes
complete sense as you as you get closer
and closer let's say you get closer and
closer to 4 either way as you get closer
and closer to 4 this is going to become
a smaller and smaller and smaller number
because this is the difference between x
and 4 so if this has become a becoming a
smaller and smaller and smaller number
then when you take 1 over that right is
you can eventually you could essentially
view this as x over x squared over x
plus 4 plus or times 1 over x minus 4 if
this is becoming smaller and smaller
this whole thing 1 over a super small
number is a super large number so as you
can imagine are going to get larger and
larger and depending on whether you're
approaching from the positive or
negative so whether this is a whether
this is a super small negative number or
a super small positive number that's
going to flip the sign but either way
the magnitude so this is we're going to
we're getting to a very large magnitude
in the negative direction because the
difference between x and 4 on this side
is negative right 3.9 minus 4
is 0.1 take the inverse of that it's 10
so we're going to we're getting negative
numbers here you take the inverse again
super large negative number so I really
want to give you that intuition but the
general way of being able to graph these
type of things
your first thing you want to do is
identify the horizontal asymptotes what
happens is we get very low the magnitude
of our X is very large so super positive
values or super negative values you
could try it out on a calculator if you
like you literally if you try out the
value million or a billion it will kind
of give you the answer but the way you
could also think about it is the other
way to think about it is as X gets
really large you could view that this
thing these terms right here grow so
much faster I mean this is just a
constant term this term doesn't matter
anymore if this is a million and a
million who cares about the 16 so as X
gets really large as X gets really large
you could say that Y is approximately x
squared over x squared these two terms
dominate you don't need to worry about
the 16 anymore and of course this is
equal to 1 which is exactly what we got
when we plugged in really large numbers
so in a problem like this where you have
the same coefficient or where this you
have the same degree on the numerator
and the denominator you look at the
coefficient of those terms so in this
case the coefficient is one and one so
our horizontal asymptote is going to be
1 divided by 1 or Y is equal to 1 if
this was 2 x squared over x squared
minus 16 our horizontal asymptote would
be y is equal to 2 we would approach
that line up there if it was a negative
2 we our horizontal asymptote would be Y
is equal to negative 2 so that's how you
identify the horizontal asymptotes where
you have the same degree in the
numerator and the denominator and the
denominator has a larger degree then the
denominator is going to get larger much
faster than the numerator and your
asymptotes going to be zero I'll show an
example of that in the future and
obviously if your numerator has a higher
degree than your denominator it's going
to grow way faster than your denominator
and you won't have any asymptotes you'll
just keep growing or keep going in the
negative direction and that's actually
the case with all of the polynomials
we've seen you could view them all as
being over 1 in which case there was no
no horizontal asymptotes now the
vertical asymptotes you'd identify by
essentially just factoring the
denominator and figuring out where does
it equal zero those are the points where
the function is not defined and I'll
show you in the future there are some
special cases where they won't be
vertical asymptotes and I guess that
special case is for example if you had
well I won't show you the special case
right now I'll show you that in a future
video but in general if you factor the
bottom terms and they don't cancel out
with anything on the numerator then
you're going to be dealing with a
vertical asymptote if I had another X
minus 4 up here if my numerator was x
squared times X minus 4 x squared times
X minus 4 and then these cancelled out
and my my expression simplified to this
the equation would still be undefined at
X is equal to 4 because you would give
you a 0 in the denominator but since
that X minus 4 cancels out with the X
minus 4 in the numerator it would have
not have been a vertical asymptote but
that's and we will look at that in the
future but this equation wasn't that so
the general rule of thumb for
identifying the vertical asymptotes
factor the denominator figure out where
the denominator equals 0 and if those
terms don't cancel out with any terms in
the numerator then those are vertical
asymptotes and then to figure out the
behavior I guess within the asymptotes
you can plot some points you can try out
some points you can actually you know
substitute values for X and figure out
what Y is now just to validate that we
hopefully got the right answer let's
actually graph let's actually graph our
rational function so let me turn it on
let me graph it let me say y is equal to
x squared divided by X divided by x
squared minus 16 and let's see what we
get nope I just want to graph it well
let me my range is off my range is off
let me do my range and let me see X
minimum value I want for X let's say
it's negative 10 my maximum value I want
for X is 10 X scale is 1 Y minimum value
I
want negative 10y maximum value I want
10 and then y-scale I want 1 now let me
graph it there we go look at that just
like what we drew we have an asymptote
as we as X gets really large or X gets
really really small that asymptote is y
is equal to 1 we have our vertical
asymptote it grafted because it tried to
connect the dots but it really it
essentially graphed our asymptotes for
us but that wouldn't actually be part of
the graph but as we approach 4 from 0 I
guess we can say we go super negative as
we approach negative 4 from 0 we get
super negative because in either of
those situations as we approach 4 from
this side this term is going to be
negative as we approach negative 4 from
this side this term right here is going
to be net well this term right here is
going to be positive but then this term
right here is going to be negative
negative times a positive you could play
with it does like we approach negative
infinity in either case and then as X
approaches infinity this thing
asymptotes away so hopefully you found
that fun